les conditions de détention des migrants
à la frontière avec le mexique soulève
l'indignation
un nouveau rapport du vérificateur
général conclut que les installations
sont insuffisantes et dangereusement
surpeuplé une situation que des milliers
d'américains ont dénoncé à travers le
pays c'est la même des états unis dix
sept manifestantes qui est attaqué une
délégation démocrate du congrès a visité
les installations où sont détenus des
migrants au texas
plusieurs en sont revenus scandalisé
c'est inhumain et embarrassant affirme
cette représentante démocrate de la
californie en mai dernier plus de onze
mille enfants non accompagnés ont été
détenus à la frontière les manifestants
attendaient les membres du congrès à la
sortie d'un centre de détention à el
paso
c'est sous les invectives que certaines
sont venus expliquer ce qu'elle avait vu
au même moment des publications racistes
sur la page facebook des agents
frontaliers éclatait au grand jour ses
agents ont publié des photos
d'alexandria occasio cortese dans des
positions sexuelles explicites
un autre message montre l'indifférence
des autorités face à la mort d'un
guatémaltèque de 16 ans s'il meurt il
meurt peut-on lire
le chef des agents parlent de cas isolés
10 dinars opposait le président chante
lui affirme que les gardes-frontière
n'apprécie pas les démocrates
il n'a pas osé dénoncer les propos de
certains agents sur facebook
le congrès vient d'octroyer 4 milliards
de dollars à l'administration trump pour
tenter de régler les problèmes à la
frontière la question est de savoir si
ce sera suffisant pour améliorer le sort
des migrants détenus ici christian
latreille radio-canada washington